hi everyone in this video we will be
talking about two topics for 3d chapter
for mathematics and IIT a preparation
the topics are basically we will be
dealing by finding doing problems on
finding perpendicular distance of a
point from a line and we will be finding
the equation of line perpendicular to
two lines given so these are small
topics however as like in many of the
math topics basically this is sort of an
approach that you should learn of how to
solve problems like these so let us
start by finding the perpendicular
distance of a point from a line the
first topic will be doing is that we
have a line we have been given let's say
a point a and that is a vector we
haven't even be vector which is a
parallel vector and we have been given a
point P let's call it P vector and we
have been asked to find the
perpendicular distance of the point from
a line so you may recall this type of
problems in 2d in straight lines
basically but it's not 3d
three-dimensional geometry so how will
we solve this problem
so one of the approaches to start this
is to think that there is a point C here
let's call it C vector and the idea is
that we know C vector would be a vector
there's some lambda B vector because
that is the line this is point is on the
line and PC vector is perpendicular to B
vector this is what we know right so we
know that these are the two conditions
we know that PC vector is perpendicular
to the parallel vector because this is
the perpendicular on the line so it has
to be perpendicular to the parallel
vector so it should flash to you that
the condition of perpendicularity is PC
vector dot B is 0 again the knowledge of
vectors is super critical in this
chapter I'm emphasize that many times in
the last two videos also PC vector is
nothing but C vector minus P vector dot
with dotted with B vector is equal to 0
and C vector is nothing but a plus
lambda B vector minus P vector dotted to
be is equal to zero right so if you if
you were to find the value of lambda
here you can get the value of lambda as
P minus a dotted with B divided by mod B
Square so now you got the value of
lambda so you can calculate the point
and then you can calculate the distance
right so I mean it's just an sort of and
for for I hope you are able to
understand and follow what we are doing
here so you can solve this equation
basically you can get associated
property you can open the brackets and
then rearrange to get this let us just
do a problem on this so that you can
quickly understand find the we have been
given P is basically 1 comma 2 comma 3
and the line is X minus 6 by 3 is equal
to Y minus 7 by 2 is equal to Z minus 7
by -2 okay
so now how will we find lambda so we
know the form of lambda I will just
suggest you to remember this but you may
want to quickly derive it in the paper
also it's up to you but I would
recommend to just remember it is very
easy to remember this P vector minus a
vector dot B vector so P minus a vector
dot B vector and divided by mod B Square
so here P vector is ICAP plus J cap a -
J cap plus 3k cap a vector is six I cap
so a vector is the one which is in the
numerator always remember the coordinate
form and how to convert it into the
vector form 7j kappa 7 k cap + b vector
is 3 i cap plus 2 J cap minus 2 k cap
right so if I were to do lambda here
this would become P vector minus a
vector which is minus 5i minus 5 J minus
4 K dotted with 3i plus 2 J minus 2 K P
vector minus a vector dotted with B
vector divided by mod B Square and mod B
Square is 3 square plus 2 square plus 2
square which is 8 plus 9 which is 17 and
if you will do this this will become
minus 15 plus 10 minus 10 Plus 8 which
is nothing but minus 17 so lambda is
equal to minus 1 okay so the point is
actually the point C is a vector minus B
vector and the point if you calculate
that point it comes out to be 3 I cap
plus 5 J cap plus 9 K cap
in the distance a PC mod would be 2
square plus 3 squared and that comes out
to be 7 ok so you can find the value of
PC mod right you can you know the point
C now so you can find a distance by just
taking the difference of x-component
square then Y complement Square and that
component square and that comes out to
be 7 and I hope that this is very
obvious for you how to solve this type
of problems and if you are still in
aren't very comfortable please practice
this make some problems yourself make an
equation of a line find a point and then
do the problems it's very easy I think
like if you do this many number of times
it should be quick for you to remember
let me give you one more homework
problem so that you can do it on your
own and the homo problem is so homework
is find a point on y axis such that
perpendicular distance from the point to
line X equal to y equal to Z is unity
okay so this is this is the opposite
question that you have been given you
have been asked to find a point and y
axis is at the perpendicular distance
from the point of the line is unity so
how will you do this problem so you can
assume a problem you can assume the
point as 0 K comma 0 comma K comma 0 and
then proceed it not completely it's the
same way you can very quickly find the
value of this thing and then you can
calculate PC and then you can equate
that to 1 to find your lis of K so
please please do this problem I think
this will give you a lot very nice
practice to understand how to solve the
problems of perpendicular distance from
a point to the line ok now let's do
another problem that is what I wanted to
do I will basically not be giving you
any physical I mean any through
something so very much I just want order
it we do an example of that problem
because that example will be enough for
you to understand so the question says
that we have been given two lines X
minus 1 by 1 equal to Y minus 2 by 2
equal to Z minus 3 by 3 right and then
you have been told that line 1 l1 is
this l2 has been given us 2x minus 2 by
4 is equal to
X minus 3 by 5 over X minus 1 by 6 ok
the question says find the line
perpendicular to l1 and l2 and passing
through 1 1 1
this has been asked as how to solve this
problem so you have been given line l1
let me say a little right answer here so
let's say this is l1 l2 you have been
given B 1 vector a 1 vector and B 2
vector and you have to find a line 3/4
which you just know one thing that it is
perpendicular to both and it passes
through the point so to find the
equation of a line you need a point
which you already have but you need a
parallel vector and what is the
speciality of that parallel vector is
that it is perpendicular to line l1 and
the third line is perpendicular to both
are on an l2 hence the parallel vector
will be perpendicular to both B 1 and B
2 and as soon as I say this it should
flash into your mind and this is
basically asking you to take a cross
product that's it I mean if you cannot
recall this please please please become
more thorough with understanding the
physical meaning of dot pretend cross
work we have discussed here dot product
perpendicular perpendicular T condition
of dot product already you have done in
the last video that our product is used
for finding angles so as soon as I use
and this it should just stick to our
minded to a vector perpendicular to the
two vectors is the Karass root of two
vectors so what you have to do is you
have to find me three vector which is B
1 cross B 2 and if you do and you should
remember that for taking cross product
you have to do this IJ K and then
opening up the determinant so if you do
that this will be I minus 3 plus J into
6 plus K into minus 3 so is this
perpendicular to both 1 2 3 so if you
take dot around with 1 so you should
remember the condition of
perpendicularity is dot dot is 0 so if
you take minus 3 plus 12 minus 9
basically dotted with B 1 is 0
if you dot with B 2 it's minus 12 plus
30 minus 18 so get 30 minus 40 is 0 so
it is per container to both B 1 and B 2
and you already have a point so the line
equation of line
three could be could be easily written
as X minus one is equal to y -1 is equal
to Z minus 1 the point has come on the
numerator and the denominator minus 3 6
and minus 3 so this line is
perpendicular to both the line and lines
and passes through 1 1 1 so I hope that
you are able to understand this
understand how important to the
understanding of vectors is here and how
I solved the problems here so we
discussed two things there one per
parent how to find the perimeter
distance of a point from a line and for
that we can remember this form of lambda
we calculated calvert lambda calculate T
the point and then when you can show at
the point you can get the coordinates of
that point and then subtract with the
original point to get the distance I
have given your homework problems so
please do that at home and then we did a
problem of finding for a line
perpendicular to the two lines for that
you need to take the cross product of
the parallel vectors and then you will
get the equation of a line ok so I hope
you enjoyed this video there are a lot
more interesting videos and topics in
this chapter so I hope to see you in the
next video thank you